ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
เป็นอย่างนี้ค่ะวันนี้
วันนี้ไวใส่ใจเปิดไวท์บอร์ดผิดนะคะนัก
เรียนไว้ป่วยกูก็เห็นไว้บ่น้อเห็นค่ะผู้
หญิงจ่ายคู่ฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
พฤหัสค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 30 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายนปีพต
อะไรคะปีพต 2  565  a  Call ศ.อะไรคะจปี
นี้คศ 2  022 ค่ะเลข 2 เมื่อวานนี้วัน
อะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 29
เดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตต
ปีพตต
2565  a  Call ศ.
ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันศุกร์
วันศุกร์อะไรก็ต้องนั้นวัน
เป็นเสียงไม่ได้ค่ะคุณมา
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันศุกร์วันที่
หมอค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มิถุนายน
เขียนยานจริงๆกีผช
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงไม่ใช่เดือนมิถุนายนนะคะ
เขียนเดือนแล้วเดือนอะไรคะวันวันที่ 1
อ่าเดือน
กรกฎาคมได้เดือนที่ 7 ร้อนเดือนกรกฎาคมปี
พตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศ
ปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะคุณฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 11:00 นสุดเด็ดโมงกี่นาที
31 นาทีค่ะ
11:31 นาทีนฮะ
โอเคคู่ฟ้าเป็นยังไงสบายดีไหม
ครูฟ้าสบายดีค่ะพี่หญิงผู้หญิงสบายดีไหม
คะผู้หญิงก็สบายดีค่ะครูฟ้ามีผู้หญิงอยู่
ที่ไหนคะ
ผู้หญิงอยู่ไม่ได้อยู่ประเทศไทยและของผู้
หญิงได้เป็นเวลากลางคืนกลางคืนแล้วกี่โมง
หรอว่าตอนนี้ของผู้หญิงเนี่ยทีที่ผู้หญิง
อยู่ตอนนี้มัน
22:00 น 31 นาทีนอน 4 ทุ่มนะพี่เอ็มนะคะ
PM สั่ง 11 นาทีตอนกลางคืนตอนกลางคืนใช่
แล้วค่ะวันนี้นะคะครูหญิงเนี่ยจะมาเช็ค
เช็ค IQ ครูฟ้าค่ะอันนี้กูไม่ขึ้นมาใช่
ไหมอ่ะดูหนัง A กูตากูฟ้านะคะจมูก
ช่วยตาครูบาใหญ่มากเลยเป็นตัด
แว่นตา
มีคู่ไม่มีขีดอยู่ที่หัวเฮ้ยหัวเป็นยังไง
ผู้หญิงกำลังจะวาดอะไรหนูฟ้าอันนี้เนี่ย
ผู้หญิงตัวมากผู้หญิงทำอะไรฮะ
ก็วันนี้เนี่ยผู้หญิงจะเช็ค IQ เชื่อไหม
เช็ค IQ ก็คือต้องเช็คที่สมองนะคะ
อันเนี้ยสมองว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ไอคิวดีทำไม IQ ดีก็คือท่านหลาดไหม
ไม่ต้องเช็ครู้แล้วว่ากูฟ้าเนี่ยไอ้คิว
280 บาท
แต่ว่า IQ  280 หรือว่าฟ้า IQ จุด 280 ฮะ
ผู้หญิงน้อยวรรคลบ
และ EQ
ถ้าไม่กี่คิวเท่าไหร่
eqb-800
อีก q800 หรือว่าไอ้คิวจุด 8 จุดศูนย์
ศูนย์นะตะวันยังไม่ได้เช็ค EQ จะเช็คน้อง
ไอ้ผิวอย่างเดียว IQ ก็พอแล้ววันนี้สนุก
จริงๆเนี่ยมีคำถามมีคำถามที่จะ
เช็คไอคิวหรือว่าความฉลาดแล้วนะคะหรือว่า
เก่ง
คำถามเกี่ยวกับอะไรผู้หญิงทั้งๆเช็ค IQ
สายไม่ยากนะคะคือฟ้าผู้หญิงไม่ได้ถามว่า
อ่ะสัก
ก็จะรู้ 6 คูณสแควรูท 7 เท่ากับเท่าไหร่
ไม่ได้เช็ค IQ แบบนี้นะไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยจะมีรู้ให้ครูฟ้าดูน้องมีรูป
นะคะแล้วก็จะถามคำถามจากรูปที่ครูฟ้าดู
ว่าผู้หญิงมีคำถามใช่ไหมว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยจะ
ตอบได้ไหมถ้าครูฟ้าตอบได้ก็โอ๊ะครูมาก็
ฉลาดนะคะสละในคิว
280 บาทแน่นอนก็ถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยตอบไม่ได้
แต่กูฟ้าก็เหลือ IQ อะ 2.8 แล้วกันแล้วก็
ไม่ฉลาดนะคะไม่
ไม่ได้ไม่ต้องเสียใจไหมถ้าไม่ฉลาด
เราไม่เสียใจมีหัวปกติมันทำให้คนฉลาดปุ๋ย
roo เคค่ะเดี๋ยว
นักเรียนจะได้รู้วันนี้นะคะว่าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยฉลาดไหมล่ะคะกลัวครูหญิงเนี่ยเล่น
แล้วผู้หญิงไม่ฉลาดนะฮะผู้หญิงเก่งขอบไม่
ได้
มีรูปนี่ค่ะครูฝากรู้มาเห็นไหมในรูปมี
อะไรบ้างในรูปมีอันนี้มีอะไรคะ
อันนี้เหมือนเป็น
เหยือกอ่ะไอ้กาแฟเหยือกใส่กาแฟอ่ะ
ผู้หญิงหลายผัวกูฟ้าดูอาจจะคิดว่าเป็น
โค้กก็ได้ใช่ไหมแต่รู้แก้วข้างล่างก็น่า
จะรู้แล้วเนาะเป็นเหยื่อกาแฟสมัยมีมือ
เนี่ยถือเหยื่ออยู่ใจห่างชายเหยือกกาแฟ
ไก่คืออีกแล้วมีตัวถ้วยกาแฟในรูปเนี่ยมี
ถ้วยกาแฟมีถ้วยกาแฟกี่กี่ใบคะมีถ้วยกาแฟ
หนึ่ง
สอง
สามสี่มีถ้วยกาแฟทั้งหมด 4 ใบจ่ายค่ะมี
ถ้วยกาแฟสีใบแล้วมีถ้วยกาแฟ aburi ไรบ้าง
มีถ้วยกาแฟ
เบอร์ 4
ค่ะเบอร์ 9
เบอร์ 5 ค่ะและเบอร์ 7 แต่ก็เบอร์ 7 ใช่
ไหมคะอ่ะอ่าเห็นรูปแล้วเนาะมีเหยื่อกาแฟ
แอสมายด์ให้เหยื่อเนี่ยเขากำลังเทใช่ไหม
กำลังเทกาแฟอยู่
อายเทกาแฟอยู่ในเหยือกเขาจ่ายแล้วก็มี
แก้วกาแฟอยู่ข้างล่างเนี่ย 4 ใบใช่ไหมคำ
ถามค่ะครูฟ้า
ถามว่าอะไรคะผู้หญิงคำถามก็คือครูมาเห็น
ใช่ไหมว่าเขาเนี่ยเทกาแฟจากเหยื่อตกาแฟ
เนี่ยมันก็จะไหลหลายๆมาแล้วก็ลงที่แก้ว
สมัยลงที่แก้วทั้ง 4 ใบเนี่ยคำถามก็คือ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยคิดว่ากาแฟที่ไหลลงมาเนี่ย
กาแฟเขาได้อะไรนะถ้วยไหนมันจะเต็มก่อน
ใช่ไหมเต็มก็คือตาไหลไหลๆจะที่นี่แล้วก็
มากขึ้นมากขึ้นแล้วก็เต็มล่ะคะกาแฟที่เท
โรงพยาบาลเนี่ยแล้วถ้วยไหนจะเต็มก่อน
กล้วยไหนแต่ก็เต็มเธออะไรกินก่อน 100 ไป
สวิงเปลี่ยนสีให้เหมือนกาแฟแล้วกันใช่ไหม
ถ้วยที่ 4
เต็มก่อนก็คือเต็มเป็นถ้วยที่ 1 หรือว่า
ช่วยที่ 9 ถ้วยที่ 5 ถ้วยที่ 7 ถ้วยไหน
เนี่ยกาแฟจะเต็มก่อน
ถ้วยที่กาแฟจะเต็มก่อนก็คือ
ผู้ที่ 5 กู้หญิงมีฟ้าบอกว่าช่วยที่ 5
ใช่ทำไมคะทำไมครูฟ้าถึงคิดว่าถ้าเทลงมา
แล้วถ้วยที่ 5 จะเต็มก่อนครูฟ้าดูสิถ้วย
ที่ 9 อ่ะมันอยู่สูงกว่าถ้วยที่ 5 นะกาแฟ
อาจจะไหลลงมาที่ถ้วยที่ 9 แล้วก็เต็มก่อน
ก็ได้
ว่าทำไมครูฟ้าถึงคิดว่าถ้วยที่ 5 เต็ม
ก่อน
เพราะว่านักเรียนดูนี่นากาแฟมาไหลมานี่
ไหนอันนี้มันไหลลงมาไม่ได้อ้ะผู้หญิงมัน
มีอันนี้ปิดไว้
หรือบันไดที่ 4 เออหมายเคลียร์ก่อนไม่
เห็นถ้าเกิดเทกาแฟเทกาแฟเทกาแฟและกาแฟก็
หลายหลายๆ
มันออกไปไม่ได้ค่ะเพื่อที่ 4 กาแฟไม่เต็ม
แน่นอนช่วยฎีกาเพลงกาแฟไม่ไหลลงมาเลยใช่
ไหมไม่ใช่ไม่เต็มไม่ไหลลงมาเลยหาซื้อที่ 9
ก็ตรงนี้เนี่ยปิดไว้นะคะกาแฟอร่อยลงได้
ถ้วยที่ 7 กาแฟก็จะไหลหลายๆรักไหมนี่เธอ
เจ็บหนักเลยเห็นตรงนี้ไหม
มันปิดไว้ให้นะเตือนฉันว่าฉันกาแฟไหล่ลง
ไปไม่ได้มันก็จะเหลือถ้วยที่ 5 เท่านั้น
เราก็มาดูด้วยที่ 5 ในกาแฟมันก็จะไลค์
ร้ายๆใช่มั้ยมันก็จะเต็มแล้วมันก็จะเต็ม
เต็มเต็มเต็มพอถึงตรงนี้มันก็จะไหลลงมา
ช่วยที่ 5 ได้ช่วยที่ 5 ไม่มีอะไรปิด
ฝาก็เลยคิดว่ากาแฟถ้วยที่ 5 จะเต็มก่อน
ไอ
ไม่รู้ค่ะอ้าวกับ
รู้สิคุยหญิงก็ต้องมีเฉลยสิมีคำถามมาถาม
ครูฟ้าจะไปเพื่อของผีเฉลย Air  crew ฟ้า
ตอบว่าถ้วยที่ 5 จะเต็มก่อนใช่ไหมคะมาดู
กันว่าครูฟ้าจะตอบถูกไหมอ่าครูฝาแดดจะ
เป็นคนชั้นลาดีหรือเปล่า
นักเรียนลาด
นักเรียนเนี่ยอ้านักเรียนคิดว่าถ้วยไหนอะ
เดี๋ยวเราให้เวลานักเรียนก่อน 10 วินาที
ลืมเลยเนาะลืมให้เวลานักเรียนคิดเลยอ่ะ
เอ่อไม่คิดเหมือนครูฟาใหม่หรือ
คิดอีกแบบหนึ่งคู่ใจค่ะโอเคกูหญิงจะมา
เฉลยแล้วค่ะครูฟ้า
น้ำๆแชร์ๆ
แห้งๆใจๆๆถูกเขา
[เพลง]
แล้วครูฟ้าโทรฟ้าก็
คู่ร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์เลยนะ
ใช่ไหมเพราะครูฟ้าบอกว่ากาแฟช่วยที่ 4
เนี่ยไม่ได้หรอตรงนี้สายตรงนี้เนี่ยมัน
ปิดเอาไว้อ่ะขอวิธี 9 ก็ปิดเอาไว้ไม่ช่วย
ที่ 9 ถ้วยที่ 7 น้ำกาแฟที่เทเนี่ยมันก็
ไหลมาไม่ได้เพราะว่ามันปิดเอาไว้
[เพลง]
กาแฟก็ไหลลงมาถ้วยที่ 5 ได้ถ้วยเดียวใช่
ไหมถ้วยที่ 5 ก็เลยเต็มก่อนตอนแรกที่กู
ฟ้าเห็นไม่รู้ว่าตอนแรกกูก็คิดคิดอะไร
ช่วยที่ 4
ทำไมอ่ะทำไมช่วยที่ 4 เพราะมันอยู่สูง
กว่าช่วยที่ 5 ใช่ไหม
ว่าคิดว่าถ้ากาแฟไหลลงมา
ช่วยที่ 9 เนี่ยอยู่สูงใช่มั้ยต้องเรียน
สูงที่สุดแต่ว่าคิดว่า
กาแฟมันไหลลงมาเสียงว่าเป็นอะไรคะ
ถ้ากาแฟมันไหลลงมาไหลลงมาอย่างเงี้ยมันจะ
ถึงหมู่ที่ 4 ก่อนไงเพราะว่าอันเนี้ยมัน
อยู่ที่นี่มันอยู่ต่ำนะคะแต่รูตรงนี้มัน
อยู่สูงนะ
มันก็เลยคิดว่ามันน่าจะถึงช่วยที่ 4 ก่อน
แล้วก็อันนี้เนี่ยมันก็ต่ำกว่าอันนี้
เดี๋ยวฟ้าคิดให้ดูนะคะเนี่ยใจค่ะ
ต้องเนี่ยมันสูงไม่เท่ากันพอกาแฟมันเต็ม
ไทยเนี้ยกาแฟมันก็จะไหลใช่ไหมคะไหล่มาทาง
นี้ก่อนก่อนที่จะไหลมาทางถ้วยที่ 5 กับ
ช่วยที่ 7 ถูกต้องแล้วก็พื้นที่ 5 ของ
พื้นที่เจ็ดเนี่ยมันยังมีที่นี่
ถ้ากาแฟไหลลงมามันจะถึงตรงนี้ก่อนถูกนัก
เรียนค่ะเราก็ต้องรอใช่ไหมรอไอ้ตรงนี้มัน
เต็มสูงๆจนเต็มมันถึงจะไหลไหลไหลๆโรง
พยาบาลได้ล่าสุดทองค่ะเพราะฉะนั้นถ้าเกิด
ตรงนี้เนี่ยมันเคลียร์หรือตรงนี้เคลียร์
ใช่ไหมฟ้าก็คิดว่ามันน่าจะเป็นด้วยที่ 4
ที่เป็นก่อน
แต่สายคือน่าจะแต่ถ้านักเรียนมันก็จะมี
เวอร์ชั่นที่กูฟ้าบอกใช่ไหมคะว่าตรงนี้
ตรงนี้แล้วก็ตรงนี้เนี่ยมันไม่ปิด
มันจะมีคำถามที่มันไม่ปิดน่ะนั้นส่วนเอง
เราก็ต้องคิดเหมือนฟิสิกส์อ้ะมันจะฟิต
ติ้งนิดหน่อยมั้ยเอ่อเราต้องคิดว่าเวลา
กาแฟที่เราเทแล้วมันไหลลงมาเนี่ย
มันจะไหลไปทางไหนได้เร็วกว่ากันหนึ่งใช่
ไหมอ่านั้นมีเฉลยไหมอ่ะชื่ออนันต์ไม่มี
อะไรไม่มีคุณก็คิดเหมือนกูฟ้า
ถ้าพรุ่งนี้ใช่ไหมตรงนี้เนี่ยอาจตรงนี้
เนี่ยเปิด
เปิดไส้ไหมคะ
ก็ไม่เอาย้อนกลับไปรูปนั้นดีกว่า
ถ้าสมมุติว่าตรงนี้เนี่ย
ไหล่ได้
พรุ่งนี้เนี่ยไหลลงมาได้แล้วก็ตรงนี้ไหล
ลงมาได้ทั้งหมดเนี่ยเปิดละไม่ปิดโดยไม่
ปิดน่ะครูฟ้าคิดว่าถ้วยไหนจะเต็มก่อน
her  Profile คิดว่าถ้วยที่ 4 ค่ะ
ทำไมอ่ะพูดไม่คิดว่าช่วยที่ 9 หรอ
หมายมาก็คิดว่าที่ 4 ทำไมอ่ะ
อ้าวนี่ไงดีเท่ากาแฟมัน
ขอทานกาแฟมันไหลมาที่นี่ใช่ไหม
เอามาไหลมาแล้วเนี่ยตรงนี้มันหาทรายๆ
นี่หานักเรียนช่องเนี้ยสองอันเนี่ยใช่
มั้ยเดี๋ยวก็มึงกูเขียน
ช่องมาอยู่ที่นี่
แต่ใหม่ number เลข 9 เนี่ย
หมายเลข 9 เนี่ยห้องมันอยู่ตรงนี้
ช่องมันสูงกว่าหมายเลข 4
ช่องมันสูงป่าค่ะนักเรียนช่องนี้นี่ไหม
เมื่อยาว่าที่นี่คือมันสูงกว่าเพราะว่า
มันสูงกว่าเพราะฉะนั้นถ้ากาแฟ
เต็มเต็มแล้วก็มันก็จะไหลมาไหลมาไหลมามัน
ก็จะถึงช่องนี้ก่อน
อายุเท่าไรขอหมายเลขสีใช่มั้ยลายลงหมาย
เลขสีอะไรลงหมายเลข 4 มันจะไม่ขึ้นมาที่
นี่อ่ะเนี่ยจะเคลียร์แป๊บนึงว่าถ้าเกิด
กาแฟมันอยู่ตรงนี้มันก็จะไปไปไปๆมันจะไม่
[เพลง]
ถ้าไม่มาที่หมายเลข 9 ใหม่ก็คิดว่านะใจๆ
ค่ะมันก็จะลงมาแก้หมายเลข 4 มันจะเต็ม
ก่อนเพราะถ้ากาแฟมันไม่ได้เต็มแล้วมันก็
ไม่ได้ไหลลงมาแล้วก็ไหลแบบนี้ใช่ไหมไม่
ได้หลายแบบนี้แต่เราเนี่ยบางครั้งเราเห็น
ใช่ไหมเราก็จะคิด
หมายเลข 9 เนี่ยช่องหมายเลข 9 มันอยู่สูง
เวลาจะแฟร์มันไหลมามันก็ต้องไหลมาทางนี้
แวะแล้วก็จะคิดว่าหมายเลข 9 เนี่ยเต็ม
ก่อนหรือว่าหมายเลข 5 ใช่ไหมเพราะว่ากาแฟ
มันไหลมาไหลมาแล้วมันก็จะไหลแบบนี้จากรูป
ที่เราเห็นแต่จริงๆเนี่ยฟิสิกส์ไม่ได้
เป็นแบบนี้
เราคิดว่ามันจะมีแค่นัมเบอร์โฟร์นะหมาย
เลข 4 เท่านั้นหมายเลข 9 ไม่มีหมายเลข 5
ไม่มีหมายเลข 7 ก็จะไม่มีมันจะมีมาที่ไหน
มีเค้ามันจะไหลดูซินีทีเดียวใช่ไหมคะนัก
เรียนคิดเหมือนครูฟ้าไว้ถ้าทั้งหมดเนี่ย
เปิดนะอันนี้มีช่องนะคะมีช่องตรงนี้ก็มี
ช่องไหลลงมาได้แล้วก็หมายเลข 7 ก็มีช่อง
ไหลลงมาทั้งหมดเนี่ยเปิดช่องทั้งหมดเปิด
นักเรียนคิดว่ากาแฟจะไหลลงมาเต็มแก้วไหน
เป็นแก้วแรกนะคะเต็มก่อนแล้วเนี่ยคิดว่า
หมายเลข 4 เหมือนครูฟ้าไหมมันก็คุณเม้น
บอกได้นะคะนักเรียนชายฝาจะว่าวีดีโอนี้
หมดเวลาแล้วเนาะเดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่
วิดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะถ้า
[เพลง]